Yeah.
Well the problem is that what defines
risk is often defined by her behavior.
The least risky thing is
what everyone is doing.
Like if you're in a hurry,
that's certainly the case.
The least risky thing is to be in the
middle of what everyone else in the herd
is doing.
Creditors can't pick you off there
and people act like that all the time.
And so,
you know,
we'll stock market investment like Michael
Risky when hardly anyone is doing it
because the way that your brain is judging
risk is by the number of people doing
it.
But as soon as everyone's doing it,
the risky thing is to be left behind
because if you're left behind,
predators will get you
your the straggling sheet.
And so what that means is the definition
of what constitutes conservative
changes as mass behavior changes.
So,
so it isn't even obvious how to advise
people as to what the conservative path
is.
Now,
you know,
standard economic adviser
would say diversify.
Well,
yeah,
I'll tell you in the 2008 crash,
you could have diversified your money
across multiple markets all over the
world.
Wouldn't help you damn bed,
everything came down.
So yeah,
you can diversify,
but that increases your transaction
costs and you have to have quite a bit of
money to do it and you have to
have quite a bit of knowledge.
And so it,
the thing is it's not that easy to make
a pile of grain lapsed and that's what
we're always trying to do.
You know,
it did.
This disappears of its own accord.
It deteriorates.
Money does that with inflation.
People are always trying
to nibble away at it,
you know?
And then now and then
there's an earthquake and
all the green disappears into
the ground.
It's hard to preserve value across time.
And you could say that about your body
there.
It's valuable.
Well in the natural state,
wolves would be after it,
you know,
it's hard to preserve value
across time and how you do that.
There's no sure fire way of doing it,
conservative way of
doing it that can fail,
a risky way of doing it that can succeed.
It also depends on what
you mean by success too.
Because to judge whether someone's a
winner or loser means you have to set a
priority standards by which to judge them.
And that is not simple.
You know,
in our culture where
people love celebrities,
they,
I'd love to be a celebrity.
Well,
sure,
that's what you think.
But Marilyn Monroe's,
it wasn't served well by,
it doesn't really look like Elvis was,
um,
you know,
there's a long list of
collapsing celebrities.
So were they successful?
Not by the standards of
reasonable longevity.
They were the,
they were successful by
Neil young standards.
Right.
Better to burn out than to fade away.
Okay.
Maybe,
you know,
maybe it's better to burn bright longer,
but it's arguable,
you know.